servus es geht so herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video und zwar dachte ich
mir es wird mal wieder zeit führen bevor
wir zweiter reden ich weiß auch nicht
was ist hier mit so auf sich hatte aber
keine sorge es kommt wieder ab dass sie
nervt ext und noch eine sache für sich
fragt herr erdiger wasserschloss
folgendermaßen meine softbox no etwa
meine softbox einfach den letzten
transport nicht überlebt und abdullah
abdullah ab aber keine sorge ich mir was
neues bestellt ist auf dem weg und
sollte so in 23 tagen das jetzt in auf
pipapo übrigens das hier ist ein
besenstiel weil ich heute mein zimmer
geputzt habe ich bin heute wieder in
meine studie gezogen und ich hab's
gefährlich love is ok kommen wir zum
punkt leute ich habe euch auf twitter
gebeten mir eigentlich extreme
persönliche worte war ungewöhnliche
fragen zu stellen janina gebäude ab über
den neuen staat ist dieser hashtag
korrekt hast du schon mal einen jungen
geküsst kammer auf save our zu ich
glaube ich gesagt nein so auf die backe
locker schon mal aber ich glaube weil
ich weiss noch nie auf dem mond nicht
dass es schlimmer oder so aber auch mir
fällt nichts dazu ein glaube ich luca
kalou schreibt national drei wörter die
mit h anfangen helene hitler hongkong
isaac in welchen situationen stehst du
dich am meisten und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen dass ich mich
wahrscheinlich in diesen frank videos am
meisten schämen als ihr bei 1 zu dieser
gamescom gemacht ich will ja nicht dass
man kann also trade center wird deswegen
glaube ich dass das einfach zu kommen
hat einst so gamescom auf das kam sehr
gut an habe ich als detail gemacht weil
wir so salat auf jeden fall weil videos
waren extrem ex
peinlich für mich zu drehen weil ich so
mensch wenn er dabei immer darüber
nachdenkt wie es jetzt ja nur person
fühlt tun die leute leid wie man so
bedrängten irgendwas rechts irgendwie
und die person verarsche dann denken
sich so die meisten prank channels
wahrscheinlich gar nichts gegen sie
einfach gar nicht ich scheiße drauf
wieder leute sich fühlen aber ich denke
mir immer so im gleichen moment sofort
auch schick wird sich diese person jetzt
gefühlt fühlt sie sich jetzt schlecht
wegen ihrer datum so ein richtig
ordentlich sprengsatz für seine muss man
ohne jetzt irgendwie zu nahe treten zu
wollen aber so bisschen stumpf sein dass
man einfach gar nichts dabei denken noch
der frage von luca kaluza
wie hat dein linien geschmeckt 44
frühstück jetzt weiß ich wo das
aufgetaucht ist alter luca postet
einfach auf snapshot ich hab das jetzt
für euch wahrscheinlich zensiert in dem
video bei dieses bild eigentlich so
nicht umgehen sollte lisa es schon
wieder erfahre ich was war der
ungewöhnlichste gedanke den du nie einer
anderen person gegenüber aussprechen
über das ironische frage weil ich mir
damit gegenüber von zehntausenden von
leuten aussprechen würde er jetzt nicht
so der ungewöhnlichste gedanke ein aber
ich habe auf jeden fall ungewöhnliche
gedanken
teilweise sind bin ich mir teilweise bin
ich mir nicht ganz sicher auch bei mir
im kopf so alles stimmen zum beispiel
habe ich halt in die spülmaschine
ausgeräumt und habe so zwei riesige
wester der hand weil ich wohl das sind
zwei riesige messer genau und ich hätte
die messer in der hand und denke so was
wir jetzt wenn du dir aber so kann man
kein leid heldin frage würdest du was
mit apo med wer würde weniger für mich
niemand würde niemanden finden würde das
also gegenüber sitzen
du findest du fährst du willst du bist
einfach wahrscheinlich jeder beziehung
mit upgrade aus musik man setzt sich zu
stunde lang gegenüber und der eine fragt
der anderen wieder fit mobil china
gefragt wann hörst du den drang dein
handy aufzuladen also ich muss dazu
sagen ich bin nicht so wie max max
rastete total aus sobald dein handy sind
99 prozent hat rente zum nächsten laden
ist sehr darauf bedacht dass er immer
sein handy gelandet ich würde so ab 55
prozent wieso dann denkt bis hin zu
langen glaube ich josi mark nippel apple
tours da fragt wie stehst du zu nippeln
wenn ich scheiße ich finde kein mensch
hat ein recht darauf und nippel so haben
nippel sollten eigentlich frei sein so
wie es vor 10.000 jahren war im land
vertrauen und es kam auch wieder fragen
zum merge leute da kann ich sagen dass
wir momentan anteilen mitte november
ideen herauszubringen
von da alle zeit der welt hat sich für
weihnachten irgendwas wünschen keine
ahnung was ich sonst dazu bestellen
mitte november ist momentan soll das
ziel also stell dich mal so auf mitte
november ein liter diesel 1 234 fragt
noch eine sehr sehr kritisch sagt uns
was war das komisch was der jemals im
leben passiert ist ich muss sagen ich
bin einmal fast von der schule geflogen
wegen kann ich sagen
ganz einfach weil ich
ok ich glaub ich hab bis jetzt auch
gerade zensiert aber weil ich das nie
erzählen möchte weil ich denn es steckt
ist vorbild aller zeiten wäre so oder so
langweilig dass gefallen hat geduldet
euch die bessere beleuchtung komm bald
wieder gamescom bald wieder ich versuche
es auch wieder regelmäßig hochzuladen
dann lasst zweier deine kommentare mitte